holiday related I understand you had a
new job well it was just for one evening
we were talking about the Polar Express
which it seems unbelievable but this was
up at the Cimarron Rose Community Center
for the city of Las Vegas up by Ann Road
in the us-95 and it was so much fun
[Music]
from the Las Vegas Academy High School
choir serenade before the start of the
show to getting everyone all aboard the
train we were ready
now meeting the dance team from
Centennial High School before the show I
could tell they'd be bringing the energy
to conferring with my fellow conductors
oh yeah we were off to the North Pole
the elves danced kids and families
danced and sang
and then
the big man showed up
we all snapped pictures with him before
heading home
and it was three nights they did
Wednesday Thursday and Friday I was
honored to be part of the conducting
crew on the the final evening big thanks
to Aaron Clark from the Cimarron Rose
Community Center for vitamy and the tip
of the conductor's cap to these Little
Engine That Could a great staff up there
at the community center energy
enthusiasm in fact Aaron talked about
most of the people attending were from
right there in the neighborhood it truly
is the definition of a community center
lots of little ones Grandma's grandpas
hot cocoa cookies Polar Express that is
awesome that is awesome and here in the
the the choir there from the uh
yeah you forget you shouldn't forget but
it's nice to be reminded how talented
those high school kids are from that
campus and they have the costumes that
were dickensian yeah